riot games is suing moon ton the
creators of mobile legends bang bang for
ripping off their game league of legends
wild rift now if that company name
sounds familiar it's because riot
previously tried to sue them for
straight up ripping off league of
legends they got a little bit of money
for that but they failed to shut the
whole thing down mainly because the
company is based in china now though
they're trying again and they've got a
whole load of new evidence for us to
look at let's get into it
look copyright infringement isn't cool
but you're going to be pretty amazed
when you see what riot is accusing these
guys of this kind of stuff does happen
fairly often in the gaming industry and
it is kind of fascinating when it
happens so if you don't want to miss it
in the future make sure you subscribe to
the channel and if you enjoyed the video
leave us a like cheers all right so last
year i made a video all about riot suing
moon ton 4 completely ripping off league
of legends the game was released in 2016
and looks nearly identical to league of
legends the art style the ui the minions
even the logos look like they've been
straight uplifted from league sometimes
this company operates exactly one step
behind riot riot makes an auto chess
game mobile legends makes one as well
wright decides to change the game's logo
after their 10-year anniversary and
mobile legends changes their logo as
well they even have their own bootleg
champion spotlights at the time riot had
been working on wild rift their own
mobile version of league of legends so
they were even more unhappy about all
this in 2017 they decided to sue moonton
the company behind mobile legends their
44-page lawsuit alleged specific
examples of champions being ripped off
by moon ton not just in mobile legends
but in another of moon town's games
called magic rush here you can see a
comparison between annie from league of
legends and emily from magic rush both
characters were little girls who deploy
fire and pet monsters to destroy their
enemies in battle and that was just one
of the examples now on the surface this
seemed like a pretty open and shut case
but there was one thing that stopped
this from being a slam dunk for riot the
suit was filed in california and moonton
are a chinese company the california
court said that because of this they
weren't the best ones to rule on the
issue and suggested that tencent riots
chinese owners take up the issue in
china's legal system tencent sued the
ceo of moon ton in china and were
eventually awarded 2.9 million dollars
and that might sound like a lot but moon
ton are the second biggest gaming
company in china this was barely a
scratch for them after the lawsuit moon
tom was forced to remove mobile legends
from google play now you might think
that would be the end of all this
madness but i have a question for you if
you were moon ton how would you overcome
this hurdle would you try and develop a
new game would you overhaul the existing
game how about something far simpler
re-releasing the game with two new words
in the title bang bang that's right
moonton released mobile legends bang
bang basically the exact same game
only with more
bang bang and so here we are in 2022
riot has launched a fresh lawsuit
against moonton in the central district
of california they state their goal is
to quote stop moon ton from continuing
its deliberate and sustained campaign to
free ride on riot's highly valuable
rights in the mobile video game league
of legends wild rift and related content
riot go on to outline the similarities
between the two games they compare ahri
in league and wild rift to mobile
legends bang bangs gwenevere the same
goes with zach and the hilariously named
glue there's even three of the dark
cosmic skins compared with a character
called eve and we return once more to
the rip-offs of both leagues old and new
logos after looking through it my
personal favorite is mobile legends bang
bangs reimagining of singed as a
character called roger yes that's right
if the mad scientist singed doesn't
scare you enough in league or arcane can
i introduce you to his even more
terrifying cousin
roger riot also provided an interesting
screenshot of a fan of mobile legends
bang bang asking moonton to make a
character similar to seraphine in league
to which they responded that they'll
pass the request on to their game
developers to satisfy the fans wishes
and if you thought the ripoff stayed in
game well you'd be wrong wright have
also accused moonton of copying their
customized wild rift night sneakers by
releasing their own shoe promotion that
features suspiciously similar gold font
and design it's honestly pretty
laughable and damning stuff all round
but then again it was when that similar
suit was filed back in 2017. the
difference now is that riot have
dedicated some pretty considerable page
space here to argue why this case should
be heard in california you'll remember
last time the california court said they
had no real jurisdiction over this and
suggested they take it to china china
has notoriously lacked intellectual
property laws and so riot's best shot is
still to have the case heard in the us
and so in the lawsuit they've laid out
no less than 12 reasons why the case
should be heard in california they state
that moonton has a u.s division in
california that it hosts servers in the
us that is contracts with apple and
google stem from the us and notably that
moonton agreed to riot's terms of
service which states that california
would be the forum for any intellectual
property disputes everything hinges on
this if riot can prove that moon ton
have enough business ties to the us that
a california court has jurisdiction it
may go to trial there and as much as i
don't want to speculate it could be hard
for muntan to wriggle out of this one if
successful riot are seeking financial
damages including all profits earned in
the us for an injunction to be placed on
moon time to stop them from doing this
in the future and for them to pay all
riots legal costs but at this point i
also wouldn't bet against moon ton
either their entire business model
seemed to be based around wriggling out
of a us court battle with riot they've
been doing it for over six years now but
have they finally gone too far can riot
get them into a court of their choice if
they do we'll be sure to let you know
yeah but it's almost some of the stuff
it's like they're almost laughing at
riot do you know what i mean like they
they could have called it anything but
it's like they're sort of taunting them
they're like look
we know you know
you know
like he's called glue
like he's literally